WILL: Gabe, Clarence
congratulations.
You've made it to the final
round of this competition.
Now we're sending
you back to your home
forges where you will recreate
an iconic weapon from history.
Make no mistake, gentlemen,
this is a tough sword to make.
The last time this was
issued as a final challenge,
one of our competitors did
not meet the parameters.
That weapon is the Viking sword.
From the eighth to 11th century,
the Vikings were the scourge
of the northern European coast.
One of their most effective
tools for raiding and pillaging
was a Viking sword, a
straight-edged iron sword with
a rounded tip and double edge.
The Viking sword
was built to break
through an opponent's defenses
using big, slashing blows.
Since the blade was heavy and
usually swung with one hand,
a large pommel and hilt
were used to balance
the weight of the blade.
Viking swords were
often highly prized
by their owners and given names
such as Battle Snake and Dog
of the Helmet.
One was featured in the
2007 epic film, "Beowulf."
This is your redemption.
This could be your last
chance to show the world
what you're truly capable of.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Best of luck to you.
Best of luck, man.
It's day one at my home forge.
I suppose it gives
me advantages.
I've never made a
Viking sword before.
But I'm feeling confident.
It's a coal forge.
I made it years ago.
This is going to be something.
By the end of the day, I'd
like to have the sword at least
partially forged--
my point established, the
bevels forged into place.
If I'm halfway down
the sword blade,
and I can finish forging
tomorrow, that would be ideal.
GABE: We're here
at Dragonfly Forge.
Today we'll be making the
billet out a few pieces
of forge welded cable, which
we'll cut, twist, weld.
The cable has about
200 strands each,
so when the two are combined,
it's going to be about 400
wires comprising the billet.
It'll make a very,
very strong blade.
Hopefully, I can get
those two put together.
That didn't quite
go how we wanted.
As I was forging the
two pieces of cable
together, the first
heat, I couldn't
get the forge weld to stick.
I just can't get the sweet spot.
I need it to be hot enough.
It's not getting
a full combustion.
And that's why
it's, like, so much
gas that it can't all burn.
The next one, I got a little
hotter, and she stuck.
The welds look great.
Today I just want
to draw out this bar.
I rethought some of the
things from yesterday,
and I think I was
a little rushed.
Today I'm going to take my time,
make sure I draw out that bar
and get that metal kind of
slimmed down, thinner, longer.
And that way, it'll
also be easier to heat.
It's hot.
I'm tired.
I'm not used to being
tired from forging.
A little bit worried
about running out of time.
So it's hard to work when
you don't have the energy.
I'm really worn out.
I hope that I can
get through this.
[bleep]
GABE: It's now the
start of day three.
Really looking pretty
darn good at this stage.
The quench is really the make
or break point of the blade.
It's about ready for
the moment of truth.
I cannot afford a failure.
The absolute worst thing that
can happen during a quench
is to have a fatal crack.
There's no choice but to
start over at that point.
Pretty damn straight.
Looks good.
We're over the largest hump
of the whole project now.
CLARENCE: Day five.
The plan is to
finish everything,
grind, put the
guard and the handle
on, and quench the blade.
Working a sword
like this by hand,
especially it being the first
of these that I've done,
there's a lot of difficulty.
The quench went all right.
We got quite a bit
of bend in here.
And I, of course,
don't want to snap it.
This is really frightening.
Got a lot of it out.
Ready to finish.
Initially, I had a
different type of pommel
set up that I wanted to do.
I'm not going to have time,
so I have to improvise.
Well, we made it
work, which is good.
GABE: It's now the
final day, and I
have all the assembly to do.
Although there's still
a lot to do today,
I'm confident I can pull it off.
The handle is a two-piece
hardwood core over the tang.
And that's going to
be wrapped in leather.
It's a very simple and
utilitarian handle design.
OK, I think that did the trick.
We only have a few hours left,
so I'm engraving the Roman
numerals XIII on here.
13 is a lucky
number in my family.
It wouldn't hurt to have
a little extra luck.
It's time to pack this thing up.
DAVID: Gentlemen, to test
the sharpness of your blade,
I'll be cutting into
our cargo net here.
Now, Gabe, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Definitely.
DAVID: All right.
Well, Gabe, that
blade made pretty
short work of that rope net.
The weight overall
has a nice feel.
Definitely did a good job.
Definitely a sharp weapon.
It felt good cutting.
Nicely done, Gabe.
Thank you.
All right,
Clarence, your turn.
You ready?
- I'm ready.
DAVID: OK.
All right, so, Clarence, a
couple of things I really
like about this blade--
the weight is very nice,
and the balance
is very well done.
This big lip in the handle,
though, is really not
very comfortable on the hand.
But your blade did
well, cut nicely.
Well done.
DOUG: Bladesmiths,
the Viking sword,
wielded by the hands of
the feared Viking warriors,
forged for one purpose--
kill the enemy.
To see how lethal
your weapons are,
I will take your Viking
sword and deliver killing
blows to this ballistics dummy.
Let's see what kind of
damage your weapon can do.
Gabe, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
DOUG: Let's do this.
OK, Gabe, the handle is
comfortable with the wrapping
that you did there.
It feels good.
As you can see, it lacerated the
chest, the chest cavity here.
It even took out some
bones of the ribs.
It is sharp on both edges
and penetrated easily
on this ballistics dummy.
Most importantly, it will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
Clarence, you're up next.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
DOUG: OK, Clarence, it
feels good to wield.
It's got great balance to it.
The one thing that it
didn't do was cut cleanly
through the ballistics dummy.
It felt like it
was bouncing off.
And I wonder if that's
your edge geometry here
being thick and the
sharpness of your blade.
But in the cuts that it did
do, the weight did penetrate,
broke some bones.
It penetrated on a
deep thrust coming out.
And that would be a
very lethal wound.
And your weapon will kill.
DAVID: Now the Viking
sword was commonly used
in conjunction with a shield.
So to test the
strength of your sword,
I'm going to take four blows
into these wooden shield
edges, two with either
edge of your blade.
Gabe, you're up first.
You ready?
- Yes, sir.
DAVID: All right.
All right, so Gabe, still
in the same shape it was in.
That's good.
It's kept its straightness.
It feels like your edge
held up really nicely.
It definitely cut
into the shield good.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right,
Clarence, you're up.
You ready?
- I'm ready.
DAVID: OK.
Well, Clarence, your
edge held up nicely.
That handle still--
ugh, in my hand,
it's still a bit of an issue.
But swinging it, the weight
and the balance is really nice.
All in all, well done.
Thank you.
WILL: Gabe, Clarence, your road
to redemption was a gauntlet.
The judges have deliberated, and
they've made a final decision.
The "Forged in
Fire" champion is--
Gabe.
Congratulations.
Clarence, please
surrender your weapon.
CLARENCE: The first
time I competed,
I wound up out in round one.
This time, I've made it
through to the finale.
So I may not be a "Forged
in Fire" champion,
but I have proven
to myself that I can
go much further than I thought.
So there'll be definitely
lots more to look forward to.
Gabe, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
that check for 10 grand.
[applause]
If that's not redemption, I
don't know what is, brother.
Feels so sweet after all that.
I love the dimensions
of that blade.
It's a great cutter.
When I was going through
that rope, it just went--
[imitates swishing]
--right through.
You definitely know how to
put an edge on something.
I feel like I've
completely redeemed myself.
It feels incredible.
Like, I never thought that the
title "Forged in Fire" champion
would mean as much as
it does to me right now.
[music playing]